Rob Riner who's a big lib has just come
out and he's asked how a Christian could
possibly vote for Trump Riner says Jesus
told us to do unto others as you would
have them do unto you how in God's name
can anyone who believes in the teachings
of Jesus support Donald Trump we hear
this line all the time we it's Rob Riner
is not the first guy to bring it up you
hear it all the time but what is he
really asking is is Rob Reiner and all
these libs are they asking how a
Christian can vote for a sinner are they
saying that Donald Trump fails to live
up to the Christian ideal of Life he's a
sinner and so therefore you can't vote
for him well that doesn't make a lot of
sense the the central Insight of the
Christian is that we're all Sinners all
have sinned and fall in short of the
glory of God and therefore we're not
going to save ourselves and we're in
need of a savior